I come out yeah we're here we're live at
Stamford Bridge seen it came behind me
John Terry there they have the trophy on
board also the leap up they won as well
didier drogba they're effectively saying
goodbye to these fallacies leaving the
club he has announced wonderful
wonderful atmosphere all the way down
here a sea of blue as far as the eye can
see all the way down towards the Kings
Road where the team will park toughest
josho marini will raise the trophy and
take a look now see the theme just
coming along way here wonderful
wonderful atmosphere Chelsea the best
team in England by a country mile this
season really and they're going to
celebrate today they have great plans
here obviously heading into next season
they want to win that trophy again they
also have aspirations towards the
Champions League but an emotional day
here this is the last time fans will see
Didier Drogba in Chelsea colors and
they're just inching their way along
their wonderful wonderful atmosphere
John Terry they're laughing away t-ball
Courtois there at the front header check
see William behind as well the entire
Chelsea first-team squad on that bus now
they're taking pictures of us as we film
them and a wonderful atmosphere all
along Stamford Bridge you can see Drogba
there he is John Terry and the trophies
in there somewhere as well let's see if
we can grab Joe Marini oh he's on board
players and the the other bus behind as
well brilliant brilliant atmosphere so
much respect for them from their fans
they've really boss that league this
season they've been brilliant and they
will celebrate so a huge huge party
later on and there Chelsea fans lining
the streets of Stamford Bridge all the
way down to the Kings Road where the
team buses will park up and they it will
celebrate in still it's been a wonderful
season for Chelsea Football Club